What was that shit that we drank
with Stan? Hope that was really good.
Was it Stan Hope? No, Stan hope wrong.
Dan Home brought it and it
doesn't some band make it.
That's the Florida Georgia line or some
shit. Cause do they make it? Is it theirs?
Yeah, it's like a pop band and they
make a good whiskey like a country band.
I think country pop and
whatever. Old Camp. Listen man,
if you call yourself country but
you get them fake rips and Eugene's,
you can go suck a bag of death.
Okay, that ain't country.
Not saying that they have that. I don't
even know. But you know what I'm saying?
Like those fake rips in the gene drive
might have a couple of little faith
groups in my team do. I checked those
fake grips drive me God damn banana.
I was like,
what are we,
we're pretending that we work hard
or what are we pretending that we,
we've had these jeans for a long time
and they're special to us or do we just
buy them off the shelf at
Macy's pre ripped like assholes.
Where the fuck did that take place?
Like if our grandparents
who made it through the
depression could come over here
and see us buying ripped jeans would they
would realize like what is wrong with
this nerved up soften down fucking
shitty country. We live in America.
It's too easy,
too easy to get by wolves in the streets.
Young Eric
can't be running around with fucking
fake rips in your genes. I mean,
I'm Brendan Schaub. One of my best friends
does that. Oh, who's this? That's them.
That's them with the five. Nailed
it. I didn't even mean to nail it.
I didn't even mean that.
I just took a wild guess.
I don't know a goddamn thing about
these fellows. Go to that other one.
Go to that last picture, right.
We put the glasses on and look at,
look at those genes. Make that bigger.
Well he looks like he got a shark.
I got some paint. Oh, you
do have some gray. Got Some
fucked up shit on your jeans.
I'm gonna. I'm gonna keep it real though.
I'm not going to like, this is sad.
Let you go in on them and not
come claim my jeans here. Listen,
I should shut the fuck up.
I'm basically wearing yoga pants.
I got these barbell jeans on.
These aren't even jeans.
These are goddamn yoga pants, jeans, or
made a weird like this thing. I mean,
well these don't, these aren't
even Jesus. These are like,
they might as well be spend decks.
I might as well be wearing yoga
pants most most pants or that now.
Even the ones that looked like jeans,
a lot of them are that they
feel better technology.
It's called advancement in
human civilization. Yeah.
You want to drive a car with leaf springs
like an asshole or do you want some
new magnetic Cadillac Escalade,
you know,
cruise through your pants or you want to
be sweaty all like the breeze from the
fake holes.
I'll take the sweat like a man.